.
Let us solve a set of graph representation issues of linear equations
There is a set of methods that allow you to graphically represent equations
What we will do in this presentation is to use the basic method
Where we will assign a set of values ​​and then
We get points
You see what I'm doing
Here I have an equation, a linear equation
I will rewrite it because this line is too small. y =
2x + 7
I want to represent this linear equation
Before I extracted the graph sheet, what I could do
Is to set a table
Where I will choose a set of x values ​​then I will be able to find
Y value that corresponds
With values ​​for x
For example, if x = - I start with a low value -
If x = -2
What is the value of y?
Well, we make up -2 in the equation
It becomes 2 × 2 + 7
= -4 + 7
This is equal to 3
If x = - I chose x values ​​in a random way
It can be a checker - maybe I'll put three or four
Points here
What happens when x = 0?
The y will equal 2 × 0 + 7
Which equals 7
what about
I will make their value higher by 2
You can choose a higher number by 1 or
You choose to prepare in a random way
When x = 2, how much is y?
It will be 2 × 2 + 7
Ie 4 + 7 = 11
I can continue to set points if you want
We have to get enough points to be able to represent them
In fact, to represent any line, we will need only two points
We have one redundant
Let me do one more solution until you clarify that
This is a line
So what happens when x = 4?
In fact, so as not to rise by 2, let's say that x = 8
Select any random number
And y will be 2 x 8 + 7, ie - well
Maybe it will come out of the graph sheet which we have - but 2 × 8 = 16
+ 7 = 23
Now let us represent it
Let me put the y axis here
This is the y axis
Let me put the x axis
I have many positive values ​​here, if we need a large extent
On the positive y axis
This is x axis
Then I will use x = -2
Which is -1
If 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8
Those are x values
Then we can move to the top on the Y axis
I will do something different because it is
The numbers will grow quickly
I will probably put it into 2 multiples
It is 2, 4, 6, 8, 10, 12, 14, 16
I can stay here, though
Let us identify these points
My first point is x = -2, and y
= 3
I can write the axes
The point will be 2,3-
x = -2
y = 3
3 Its location is here
If this point is first,
Then the next point
0.7
I'll give it that color
x = 0
Y = 7
Here
0.7
We have these green in here
Point 2.11
2.11 will be here
2.11
Then another point - these actually will fall
Of graphic representation
8,23
You will be here at the top somewhere
If you can see what I do
It's 8,23
If we get points, you'll see that the line consists of a line. Let me
The origin of these points
I painted them manually as it is obvious so maybe this will not be
The line is finely straight
If you have a computer, use it, where the line will be straight
You can continue to choose x values ​​and find
Y values ​​that correspond to it
In case y is an association of x values
If you keep setting each point, you'll get a line
If you select all the possible x values ​​and set them all, you will get
Each point on the line
Let's solve another issue
At the airport, you can change your currency from
Dollars to euros
From dollars to euros
The service cost is $ 5
For every dollar, you get 0.7 euros
Make a table of this and assign the pairing to the graphic representation
Use the graphic representation to determine how many coins in euros you will receive
If you give the office $ 50
I will write EUR = - Let us see if, will convert
To dollars
And even if you get euros you have to give them the dollar
If they take $ 5
If $ 5
This service costs $ 5
All that remains is this
The rest - you'll get 0.7 euros for every remaining dollar
You'll get 0.7 for everything left
If this is the relationship
Now we can assign points - we can answer the
Their question
If you give them $ 50, we do not have to look at the graphic representation
But we'll look at the graphic representation later
If you put EUR = - if you give them
$ 50-- will be 0.7 x 50-5
I gave them 50
They took 5 for the service
If $ 45 remains, it will be 0.7 x 45
I will do this here
45 x 0.7
7 x 5 = 35
4 × 7 = 28, + 3 = 31
Then we have only one number left behind the comma
This is only 7
If output is 31.5
If you give them $ 50, you get € 31.5
EUR, not dollars
If we answer the question, but let us
We represent it graphically
Let's draw a table
Maybe I'll pull out the calculator
I'll point out something to him
Let's put the dollars you gave them
Dollars
How many euros did you get?
I will set a random set
If you give them $ 5, they will
$ 5 of them for service
You will receive $ 5 - 5, ie 0 × 0.7
If you do not get anything in return
So there is no good reason to do this
Then if you give them $ 10
What will happen?
If you give them $ 10, 10 - 5 = 5 x 0.7
You'll get $ 3 - or maybe I should say € 3.50
You will get € 3.50
Now what happens if you give them $ 30?
Or actually let me say 25
If you give them $ 25, 25 - 5 = 20
20 x 0.7 = $ 14
I will put another value
Let's say you gave them $ 55
This makes the calculation simpler for you
5 will be subtracted from the issue
55 - 5 = 50, × 0.7 = $ 35
Is this true?
Yes thats right
You will get 35 euros
All in euros
I just kept telling the dollar
Let us help them
All these values ​​are positive, if only I should
Draw the first quarter here
All these values ​​are positive
If the dollar - let us put staging multiples of 5, ie 5, 10, 15
20, 25, 30, 35, 40, 45, 50, 55
I have drawn a x axis a little shorter than I needed
This is up to 55
Then y axis
Staging will be a 5-fold multiplication
5, 10, 15, 20, 25, 30, 35
Well, that's more than I need
Now let us identify these points
I will give them $ 5
Get 0 euros
This euro
This is the dollar
The dollar is an independent variable and we have found
The euro through it
Or that the euro depends on
The dollars I have
If I gave them $ 10, I would get € 3.50
3.50 - Difficult to read
Maybe 3.50 is located here
If I gave them $ 25, I would get 14 euros
25,14 Located here
As it is clear, so this fee is manual, so it will not be
Very accurate
If I give them $ 55, I'll get 35 euros
If 55,35 fall here
If you want to connect points, you have to get something
Looks like a font
If you do this - if you are a computer
The line will be exact
It looks very good
Then we can observe what we are required to do
We use graphic representation to determine how many euros we will get
If the office is given $ 50
The 50 here
We will start if
I will make a graph
The age we go all this way - in fact, I painted another
Point on the graph incorrectly some thing
Let me
35 is located here
Let me redraw that point
35 is located almost here
If 55,35 fall here
Let me redraw the line
It will look - I have forgotten 25
25,14 Located here
I will make the Baidu chart so
That's my best
Now let us answer the question
Here we gave them $ 50
We go up, up, to $ 50
He will get a
We continue to go on the left side
This is approximately 31.50
We created it using the formula
But you can see, you can observe it from the graph and
Find any value for the dollar
If you give them $ 20, we'll go all this
the path
And you'll find it must be - well, $ 20 must be equal
7.50
The inaccuracy in the official graphic makes it
Less subtle
When you say 20 - 5 = 15
15 × - in fact it will be a little more
From $ 10, this is true
You will be here
If you put $ 20 here, 20 - 5 = 15
15 x 0.7 = $ 10.50, which is located here
You can look at any point in the graphic representation and find
The number of euros you will receive
Let us represent these while we do
Read the graph
Graph - I think we were told to use the chart below
Oh, the graph illustrates converting the representation to
Conversion between weight per kilogram
Weight in pound unit
Use it to convert the following measurements
We have a kilogram here and a pound here
If required 4 kg per pound unit
If we look at this here, 4
Kg here
We follow the chart
If 4 kg to a pound, it will look, I do not know
Just below 9 lbs
Less than - then
I will write about 9 lbs
You can not see it exactly
It is less than 9 pounds slightly
4 kg. To 9 kg, we go here
9 kg. We go to the top
It looks like it's about 20 pounds
Here we have 12 pounds to convert to kilograms. In fact
The kilogram is a mass, but I do not want to get it accurately
12 lbs
We go here
pound
12 pounds per kilogram, it looks like 5 1/2
Approximately 5 1/2
Then 17 lbs to kg
If 17 here
17 lbs to a kilogram, it looks like 7 1/2 kg
Anyway I wish these examples made you
It is somewhat comfortable with the representation of equations graphically and reading representations
For equations
See you in the next view
.